1916, solo 13 años después de que los hermanos
Wright volasen el primer aeroplano más pesado
que el aire, nacía una empresa americana
dispuesta a revolucionar la recién nacida
industria de la aviación.
Fundada como la Pacific Aero Products y renombrada
apenas un año después como Boeing, esta
empresa encadenó éxitos durante décadas
y desarrolló algunas de las mejores tecnologías
y muchos de los mejores aparatos de cada momento.
Desde el primer avión comercial moderno,
el Boeing 247, lanzado en 1933, hasta el icónico
Jumbo 747, Boeing ha sido capaz de sorprender
a la humanidad durante décadas… hasta que
llegó Airbus.
[Pero..
Antes de meternos de lleno en el tema de hoy...
Es un hecho: ¡se acerca el verano!
-Si vives en Madrid no te tendré que convencer
demasiado-
¿Y no es el verano acaso la mejor época
para aprender un nuevo idioma con el que poder
comunicarte en tus viajes, o incluso pillar
un curro veraniego en el que hables con turistas?
Pues atentos porque en Babbel han diseñado
un método pensando en ti:
Con sus audios y podcasts Babbel se encarga
de darte todas las herramientas para que puedas
darle un empujón a ese idioma que siempre
has querido dominar sin tener que trastocar
tu día a día.
Mientras paseas al perro…
Viajas en metro..
Compras en el súper…
Cualquier momento es bueno para aprender con
Babbel.
Y no solo eso, también cuentan con recursos
como juegos, reconocimiento de voz, clases
culturales y, por supuesto, lecciones según
tu nivel.
Déjate de excusas.
Échale un ojo a los 14 idiomas que puedes
aprender con Babbel, escoge el que te motive
y aprovéchate de un descuentazo de hasta
el 50% con el enlace que te dejamos en la
descripción.]
Y ahora sí, continuemos.
90 años después del lanzamiento del icónico
Boeing 247, hoy el mundo de la aviación es
radicalmente diferente.
Boeing no solo ya no lidera el mercado, sino
que ha sido superado por un competidor con
casi la mitad de años de vida: Airbus.
Fijaos en este gráfico.
Lo que veis es una guerra muy reñida, un
mercado repartido entre dos grandes colosos
donde, sin embargo, Airbus está ahora llevando
la delantera.
En la mayor parte de los últimos 20 años,
la europea Airbus ha registrado más pedidos
que su rival norteamericano.
La pregunta, ¿por qué?
¿Cómo es posible que los europeos hayan
logrado batir a la poderosa industria de la
aviación comercial norteamericana?
Quizás, muchos estéis pensando que este
cambio tiene mucho que ver con el fiasco del
Boeing 737 MAX, un avión que estuvo 20 meses
en tierra porque las autoridades de seguridad
aérea le prohibieron volar tras registrarse
dos mortales accidentes.
Y sí, en cierto modo esto tiene mucho que
ver con lo ocurrido, al fin y al cabo el 737
Max era la gran esperanza de Boeing.
Aunque no vamos a profundizar mucho en esta
cuestión porque, aquí en VisualPolitik,
ya hicimos un vídeo íntegramente dedicado
a este tema.
Os dejo el enlace al final del vídeo.
Pero no, esa no es la única razón que explica
por qué Airbus ha logrado adelantar a su
rival estadounidense.
En este caso la historia viene de mucho más
lejos.
¿Nunca os habéis preguntado cómo diantres
una empresa de aviones europea logró ponerse
a la altura, en calidad y tecnología, del
gran líder americano que controló está
industria prácticamente desde su nacimiento?
¿Cómo nació Airbus?
¿De quién fue la idea y por qué se creó?
¿Quién ha puesto la pasta para que consiguiera
mirar de tú a tú a Boeing?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿Qué demonios tiene que ver todo esto con
VisualPolitik?
Queridos amigos, amigas, la historia de Airbus
y su guerra con Boeing es más que una historia
de competencia entre dos empresas, es también
una historia de competencia política: Estados
Unidos versus la Unión Europea.
El viejo gigante versus el nuevo mastodonte.
Y creedme si os digo que hay mucha, pero que
mucha tela que cortar.
Esta es una historia que va mucha más allá
de la propia aviación.
Así que…
¿Estás preparado?
¿Tenéis los cinturones abrochados?
Pues…
Arranquemos.
(LA UNIÓN HACE LA FUERZA)
La segunda mitad del siglo XX fue la época
de la explosión económica y la modernidad
tanto en Occidente como en buena parte de
Asia.
Y también fue la época en la que Europa
se levantaba de las cenizas de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial.
Donde antes había peleas y conflictos constantes,
ahora de repente había acuerdos y cooperación.
De hecho, si esto no hubiera sido así, probablemente
Airbus jamás habría existido.
La empresa aeronáutica europea por excelencia
nació en 1970.
Fue el resultado de una negociación política
entre gobiernos que había empezado ya unos
cuantos años antes.
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis.
Airbus no fue una iniciativa que surgiera
de algún empresario visionario ni nada por
el estilo.
La idea salió de los despachos de los propios
gobiernos de Francia y de Alemania Occidental
a finales de los años 60.
Para lograrlo, estos gobiernos propiciaron
la unión de la aeronáutica francesa Aerospatiale
y la alemana Deutsche Airbus.
Más tarde se unieron al consorcio las empresas
aeronáuticas de España y el Reino Unido.
En esencia, la idea era replicar la colaboración
que habían hecho los franceses y los británicos
para crear el Concorde unos años antes, pero
en este caso con el objetivo de crear una
estructura a largo plazo que permitiera hacer
aviones, digamos, menos exclusivos.
Aviones que primero tenían que ser capaces
de llenar un hueco en el que las americanas
Boeing, Lockheed y McDonnell Douglas, que
acabaraban cerca del 80% del mercado, no tenían
ningún producto.
Y más tarde competir con ellos, directamente,
a gran escala.
Y así es como el primer aparato en nacer
fue el Airbus A300, que fue el primer avión
de fuselaje ancho en hacer vuelos comerciales
con dos motores bajo las normas ETOPS y del
cual ya os hemos hablado con mucho detalle
en nuestro canal hermano Megaprojekts.
Si os interesa la historia de este avión
os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.
Pero, no nos desviemos y pongámonos en situación.
(Con los europeos fabricando aviones modernos
y ganando poco a poco cada vez más mercado
gracias a la unión de varias empresas, Boeing
tenía que hacer algo.
Así que en 1997 trató de replicar el modelo
adquiriendo a su competidor directo americano:
la McDonnell Douglas.
Sin embargo, con esta compra, el gigante americano
heredó algunos de sus problemas, entre ellos
económ icos y de cultura corporativa que
sí, tarde o temprano le pasarían factura.)
Sea como sea, el caso es que había empezado
la era del que quizás es el duopolio más
importante y poderoso de todos los que puedan
existir: el de la aviación.
Ahora bien, no vayamos tan rápido.
Esta es una industria que requiere de muchísima
inversión en capital, es decir, para que
funcione hay que poner mucha pasta.
Como os podéis imaginar, diseñar, desarrollar
y fabricar aviones no resulta nada fácil.
La pregunta es: ¿Quién iba a poner la pasta
para desarrollar la tecnología que les permitiera
a cada una de las dos empresas intentar conquistar
el mercado?
Por primera vez Boeing tenía enfrente suyo
a un potencial gigante capaz de mirarles de
tú a tú, pero…
¿Cómo competirían exactamente?
¿Cómo pretendían los europeos conseguir
eclipsar al gigante norteamericano?
Pues veréis, insisto, para lanzar un nuevo
programa, para crear un nuevo avión hacen
falta sobre todo dos cosas: la primera es
dinero, montones y montones de dinero.
Pero para que os hagáis una idea más clara
de lo que estamos hablando, pongamos un ejemplo
concreto, echemos un vistazo al caso del A380
de Airbus, el avión de pasajeros más grande
del mundo que se dejó de fabricar en marzo
de 2021 cuando salió de fábrica el último
aparato.
Pues bien, fijaos.
(El programa del A380, que incluye todo el
ciclo de desarrollo, desde la idea conceptual
hasta su puesta en servicio, se estimó inicialmente,
en el año 2000, que costaría unos 11.300
millones de dólares.
Sin embargo, los cálculos hoy apuntan a que
el desarrollo de este gigante de los cielos
se tragó más de 30.000 millones de dólares.)
Son cifras estratosféricas.
Y, ojo, porque la propia Airbus reconoce que
el A380 jamás le ha dado beneficios.
Bueno, no es que no haya gen erado beneficios,
es que por el camino se perdieron miles de
millones de dólares.
Y aquí es dónde llegamos a la segunda cosa
que hace falta para lanzar un nuevo avión.
Además del dinero, hace falta que exista,
obviamente, demanda suficiente.
Dados los números que se manejan, unas previsiones
mal hechas pueden hacer que el desarrollo
del nuevo avión se termine convirtiendo en
una ruina.
Pues bien, justo aquí llegamos a la parte
más controvertida de este duelo de titanes.
La pregunta es, ¿qué ha hecho Airbus mejor
que los americanos?
Pues para muchos estadounidenses lo que ha
hecho Europa con Airbus no es sino competencia
desleal.
Una situación, queridos amigos, que llegó
a provocar toda una guerra comercial entre
Estados Unidos y el bloque europeo.
Fijaos.
(EE.UU. y la UE acuerdan suspender la disputa
comercial entre Airbus y Boeing
La disputa comercial de 17 años es la más
larga y costosa en la historia de la OMC.
Los importadores de EE.UU. han pagado más
de 1.100 millones de dólares en aranceles
desde que los aranceles en disputa entraron
en vigencia en 2019, según datos de la Oficina
de Aduanas y Protección Fronteriza de EE.UU.
- Wall Street Journal)
Ahora bien, ¿queréis saber exactamente en
qué consiste y por qué se ha producido este
conflicto?
¿Realmente Airbus ha crecido gracias a un
trato de favor por parte de los gobiernos
europeos?
¿Ha sido este un ejemplo de competencia desleal?
¿Y qué hay de Estados Unidos?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (GUERRA DE EGOS)
La disputa comercial entre Estados Unidos
y la Unión Europea, y entre Boeing y Airbus,
con la Organización Mundial del Comercio
de por medio, tenía una causa muy clara:
la financiación.
Y es que, veréis, Airbus, el fabricante europeo
de aviones, ha estado recibiendo desde sus
inicios enormes cantidades de dinero público
para poder afrontar el coste que tiene el
desarrollo de nuevos aviones.
Pero, veamos algunos datos.
A lo largo de la historia del consorcio, los
gobiernos de Francia, Alemania, Reino Unido
y España, a los que después se sumaron otros,
han inyectado toneladas de billetes.
Dinero en forma tanto de subsidios directos
como de préstamos a intereses artificialmente
bajos o, directamente, sin ningún tipo de
coste financiero, es decir, sin intereses.
Hablamos de ayudas que podrían llegar a superar
los 15.000 millones de dólares, pero cuyo
impacto en el mercado podría según algunos
cálculos rondar los 200.000 millones de dólares,
jugando todo esto, lógicamente, en contra
de la estadounidense Boeing.
Toda esta financiación es lo que se denominó
como “ayudas de lanzamiento” y conforman
uno de los mayores planes de política industrial
en Europa durante las últimas décadas.
(Básicamente, los estados cubrieron con estos
instrumentos una parte importante del coste
del desarrollo de los primeros modelos de
Airbus, como el A300 o la familia de aviones
de tamaño medio, como la del A320, que compite
con eeel Boeing 737.
El conflicto viene porque, inicialmente, la
idea era que estas ayudas fueran reduciéndose
hasta desaparecer a medida que Airbus fuese
madurando en el mercado.
Y también porque tendrían que ser devueltas
en su totalidad a medida que cada programa
tuviera beneficios.
Es decir, la empresa iba a ser apoyada con
dinero de los contribuyentes europeos en su
despegue con la expectativa de retornar en
un beneficio mayor.)
Vamos, básicamente, un plan típico de política
industrial, que seguro, seguros, muchos de
vosotros veis con buenos ojos.
Al fin y al cabo, Airbus fue un éxito y bueno,
puede que también penséis que es mejor dedicar
los recursos públicos a iniciativas como
esta que no a otro tipo de cuestiones…
Digamos más etéreas, menos productivas.
Por supuesto sobre esta cuestión habría
mucho que decir, pero de eso nos encargamos
en nuestro canal hermano, VisualEconomik.
El caso es que, sea como sea, como os podéis
imaginar, los estadounidenses no lo ven con
buenos ojos.
Y menos aún si tenemos en cuenta que ni estas
ayudas terminaron por desaparecer ni Airbus
ha devuelto la totalidad de estos préstamos.
(6 de marzo de 2019: Airbus en disputa por
600 millones de dólares de préstamos impagados
utilizados para desarrollar el A380
Según Reuters, Airbus afirma que "ya no tendría
que pagar ningún préstamo estatal pendiente
sobre el A380 porque los gobiernos habían
acordado compartir el riesgo en el proyecto
de aproximadamente 15.000 millones de euros.”
- Simple Flying)
Ya lo veis, estas “ayudas de lanzamiento”
fueron tan ventajosas que por lo visto incluían
una cláusula por la que, si el programa iba
mal, el riesgo era compartido entre el que
presta, o sea, los gobiernos, y el que recibe:
Airbus.
Es decir, que ambos se repartirían las pérdidas…
Cosa que por cierto no ocurre con los beneficios.
De hecho, no es que Airbus pierda dinero.
Sí, el programa del A380 fue mal, pero la
empresa va viento en popa.
Por e wwjemplo, en 2022, esta empresa obtuvo
un beneficio neto, es decir, después de impuestos
de más de 4.200 millones de euros, el mejor
resultado de toda su historia.
Pese a ello, parte de las pérdidas del programa
del A380 se la han comido los Estados.
[Y la verdad, no sé si esto tiene mucho sentido]
Pero, sea como sea, lo que está claro es
que a los americanos no les gusta ni un pelo.
El cabreo es monumental.
Tanto en la sede de Boeing como entre los
políticos de Washington.
Bajo su punto de vista, los europeos han estado
torpedeando su industria aeronáutica con
supuestas ayudas ilegales.
Y de hecho, la Organización Mundial del Comercio
llegó a fallar que este tipo de préstamos
a Airbus generaron competencia desleal.
Así que, ¿qué queréis qué os diga?
Algo de razón tenían.
Para poder firmar la paz con Washington y
acepar las directrices de la OMC, la Unión
Europea, Francia y España tuvieron que elevar
los intereses que le cobran a Airbus por los
préstamos ligados al lanzamiento del A350,
uno de los nuevos programa estrella del fabricante
europeo.
Ahora bien, stop, echad el freno.
Antes de que inclinéis la balanza a favor
de unos u otros, esperad un poco porque como
solemos insistir en VisualPolitik…
toda historia tiene al menos dos versiones.
Y es que los estadounidenses tampoco se han
estado comportando como hermanitas de la caridad.
Para nada.
De hecho, podríamos incluso decir que el
gobierno estadounidense ha sacado de muchos
apuros a Boeing en los últimos años, y lo
ha hecho utilizando varías vías diferentes.
Alguna de ellas, por cierto, con consecuencias
catastróficas.
¿Queréis saber de qué estamos hablando
exactamente?
¿Queréis conocer las artimañas de los norteamericanos?
Pues…
¡Atentos!
T3 (RESCATES…
¿EN DIFERIDO?)
Ya os hemos contado que Airbus ha recibido
muchísimo dinero por parte de los contribuyentes
europeos.
Dinero que en muchas ocasiones ha sido perdonado,
lo que claramente ha perjudicado a Boeing
en su competencia con Airbus, pero…
¿Qué hay de los americanos?
¿Se han quedado con los brazos cruzados?
Pues evidentemente no.
Ni unos son tan buenos, ni otros son tan malos.
Boeing también ha estado recibiendo miles
de millones de dólares en financiación del
gobierno estadounidense y para muchos, también
enormes tratos de favor.
Tratos de favor, que según se apunta, han
venido en ocasiones de la propia Agencia Federal
de Aviación de Estados Unidos, la hasta hace
poco muy respetada FAA, el organismo que se
encarga de regular y supervisar todas las
actividades relacionadas con la aviación
civil en los Estados Unidos.
La pregunta es…
¿Cómo lo han hecho?
Pues veréis, la forma que ha tenido - y que
sigue teniendo - Estados Unidos de financiar
a Boeing es a través de multimillonarios
contratos militares y aeroespaciales, que
muchos consideran que se otorgan, inflados
de precio.
Es decir, como si se tratara de una subvención
oculta.
De hecho, ojo a los datos: Los mayores contratistas
de Boeing son ni más ni menos que la NASA,
el Departamento de Defensa y el Departamento
de Seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos.
Tan solo o en el año 2017, Boeing ganó 23.400
millones de dólares en contratos públicos
en Estados Unidos, según los datos recopilados
de la Administración de Servicios Generales.
Y de hecho, en su defensa, Airbus alega que
los constantes y numerosos contratos que Boeing
recibe desde el gobierno estadounidense y
desde agencias públicas son una forma de
subsidiar al gigante americano de la aviación.
Pero no solo eso, también están los supuestos
tratos de favor por parte de la FAA que os
comentábamos hace un momento.
Fijaos.
(La FAA vio un alto riesgo de accidentes,
pero dejó que el Boeing 737 MAX siguiera
volando - The Seattle Times)
C1 ([Los accidentes del Boeing 737 MAX] “fueron
la horrible culminación de una serie de premisas
técnicas erradas de los ingenieros de Boeing,
una falta de transparencia por parte de la
gerencia de Boeing y una supervisión extremadamente
insuficiente de la FAA” - Informe de la
Comisión de Transporte e Infraestructura
de la Cámara de Representantes de Estados
Unidos)
(La FAA y Boeing manipularon las pruebas del
737 MAX durante la recertificación - The
Verge)
En efecto, todo apunta a que, además del
dinero que Estados Unidos inyecta cada año
en Boeing a través de contratos, también
estuvo ayudando a la compañía dándole ciertas
facilidades a la hora de certificar sus aviones.
Concretamente, el caso del 737 MAX, que fue
un avión que se diseñó tarde y mal para
competir con el Airbus A320neo, que fue lanzado
prácticamente por sorpresa y contra el que
Boeing se vio fuera del mercado e incapaz
de competir.
Si estas sospechas se confirman, lo que podemos
decir es que el resultado fue trágico.
Pero ojo, que todavía no os hemos hablado
de los incentivos fiscales.
(12 de marzo de 2020: El estado de Washington
revoca la exención de impuestos a favor de
Boeing; Estados Unidos espera evitar los aranceles
de la UE
Los cambios eliminarían el ahorro del 40
% en el impuesto de uso y ocupación, que
ahorró a Boeing unos 118 millones de dólares
en 2018 según los ingresos publicados de
aviones de pasajeros. - Reuters)
¿Una exención fiscal para una empresa en
concreto?
¿No son estas cosas ayudas públicas que
también perjudican a la libre competencia?
¿No son acaso un trato de favor por parte
de las administraciones estadounidenses hacia
Boeing?
Pues… lo cierto es que la Organización
Mundial del Comercio no solo falló en contra
de Airbus, también lo hizo en contra de los
americanos.
(La OMC dictamina que EE. UU. no detuvo las
exenciones fiscales injustas para Boeing)
EE.UU. no había hecho cumplir una orden de
2012 para detener los subsidios al fabricante
de aviones de EE.UU. a través de exenciones
fiscales del estado de Washington.
La ventaja competitiva abusiva provocó la
pérdida de ventas de los aviones de pasillo
único A320neo y A320ceo de Airbus en cinco
campañas de ventas.
- Financial Times)
Con lo cual, ¿qué queréis qué os diga?
Ambos gigantes han pecado de hacer lo mismo
pero de diferentes maneras.
Esta es una historia en la que no hay ni buenos
ni malos…
Pero sí grandes, “paganinis”: los contribuyentes.
Porque sí, puede ser razonable apoyar el
desarrollo de grandes proyectos tecnológicos
e industriales, pero quizás las ayudas tendrían
que ser más justas, limitadas y abiertas
a más empresas, ¿no os parece?
El caso es que firmar la paz comercial por
esta tema entre Estados Unidos y Europa no
ha sido nada fácil, ni tampoco algo que haya
caído del cielo.
Es más, ha habido un motivo que ha jugado
un papel clave en el fin de la guerra entre
las dos empresas y los dos bloques.
¿Os imagináis cuál puede ser?
Pues…
Atentos.
T4 (LO QUE CHINA HA UNIDO QUE NO LO SEPARE
EL HOMBRE)
17 años de guerra entre las dos principales
empresas de aviones del mundo pasan factura.
Al final es algo que repetimos mucho en VisualPolitik:
las guerras comerciales no suelen beneficiar
a ninguna de las partes.
Y el caso de Boeing y Airbus no es diferente.
Ambos fabricantes se han estado haciendo daño
mutuamente…
Y por extensión se lo pueden haber hecho
al desarrollo de la industria.
La guerra entre Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea elevó los costes de importación
y exportación, restringió el uso y el desarrollo
de tecnologías y al final encareció los
aviones y ralentizó la evolución de la industria.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Esto creó un caldo de cultivo ideal para
que otros intentaran aprovechar el río revuelto.
Ahora le han visto las orejas al lobo.
Y sí, el lobo es, otra vez, China.
("También acordamos trabajar juntos [UE y
EE.UU.] para desafiar y contrarrestar las
prácticas antimercado de China en este sector
que otorgan a las empresas chinas una ventaja
injusta".
- Joe Biden)
Es algo que también os lo contamos en un
pasado vídeo en nuestra particular serie
de vídeos sobre el mundo de la aviación,
el duopolio Airbus-Boeing podría estar amenazado,
al menos en el segmento del corto y medio
radio, por un nuevo competidor: la china COMAC.
Pekín está utilizando agresivamente una
mezcla de las dos formas de subsidios públicos
que hemos visto en este vídeo, las utilizadas
por los europeos y las utilizadas por los
americanos.
El gobierno chino está subvencionando directamente
el desarrollo de aviones, y está también
realizando enormes pedidos a través de sus
aerolíneas estatales.
De hecho, el COMAC ARJ21, con capacidad para
hasta 100 pasajeros, ya realiza vuelos comerciales,
y el COMAC EC919 está en vuelos de pruebas.
Aunque ha encontrado algunos problemas y puede
que su entrada en servicio se retrase desde
lo previsto para 2023, lo cierto es que este
avión puede suponer una enorme amenaza para
el futuro de Boeing y de Airbus.
Hablamos de un avión que puede transportar
hasta 174 pasajeros y que, por tanto, compite
directamente con el A320 y el 737 en China,
los buques insignia de los dos gigantes occidentales.
Es más, China espera fabricar 150 de estos
aviones al año para el año 2028.
Y este escenario, el de un fabricante aeronáutico
para el mercado chino de corto y medio radio,
sería la peor de las pBesadillas para Airbus
y Boeing.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque China es el mercado clave para
el futuro de los dos gigantes de la aviación.
De hecho, según cálculos de la propia Boeing,
el gigante asiático necesitará comprar,
mucha atención, casi 8.500 nuevos aviones
de pasajeros de aquí a 2041.
Esto es una verdadera salvajada, con lo que
si un competidor local como COMAC consiguiera
llevarse aunque sea una parte importante de
ese pastel, el futuro de Boeing y de Airbus
podría cambiar por completo.
Un torpedo a la línea de flotación del negocio.
Así que ambas empresas - y los gobiernos
de Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea - lo
que han hecho ha sido tirar de pragmatismo.
Ambas empresas han abierto en los últimos
años líneas de ensamblaje final en China
para algunos de sus modelos más demandados,
como el Boeing 737 o los Airbus A320 y A321neo.
Además, la Unión Europea ha ofrecido a Estados
Unidos enterrar las dichosas “ayudas de
lanzamiento” a Airbus, a cambio de financiar
al consorcio a través del gasto militar.
Algo que ya estamos viendo.
Fijaos.
(España prestará a Airbus 2.140 millones
de euros para programas militares - Reuters)
Sí, tal y como muchos estaréis pensando,
esto es prácticamente adoptar el modelo americano
de financiación a Boeing contra el que durante
17 años ha estado luchando Bruselas.
[En fin, quien los entienda que los compre.]
Lo que se sabe hasta ahora es que ambos bloques,
la UE y Estados Unidos, han firmado una tregua,
un alto al fuego en esta guerra comercial,
la cual en teoría debería solucionarse antes
de 2026.
¿El futuro?
Pues no lo podemos saber a ciencia cierta,
pero lo que está claro es que ni Airbus ni
Boeing están en condiciones de echarse demasiado
en cara en cuanto a esto de la competencia
desleal.
Los dos gigantes industriales han recibido
enormes cantidades de dinero, los dos controlan
más o menos una porción parecida del mercado,
y los dos tienen enormes conexiones políticas
con el sector público.
Pero ahora llegados hasta aquí es turno para
ti: ¿crees que Airbus y Boeing lograrán
firmar la paz de forma definitiva?
¿Deberían ambas empresas empezar a colaborar
para evitar que los chinos se abran paso en
el mercado?
¿Cómo crees que puede ser la guerra por
el control de los cielos en las próximas
décadas?
Déjanos tus opiniones aquí abajo, en los
comentarios.
Y no lo olvides, es hora de aprender ese idioma
que te hace falta con un 50% de descuento
en Babbel, usando el enlace que encontrarás
abajo.
Recuerda también que si te gusta lo que hacemos
puedes apoyarnos sumándose a nuestra comunidad
en Patreon en alguno de los seis niveles diferentes
que tenemos.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.